three-two-one welcome thanks for doing
this man I really appreciate it thanks
for inviting me this is awesome I've
seen a bunch of videos online of you
talking about space and your your your
dream of being an astronaut as a young
man and what what is it like just to see
the Earth from above and to be you lived
up there for like what 95 days 95 days
which actually is kind of a bummer to be
honest with you because you know this if
you saw that video maybe yeah the thing
is if you stay for a hundred days they
give you a patch right I'm a day 95 and
the space shuttle Discovery shows up to
bring me home and Mark Kelly was a
commander he goes Garret it's time to
hop in and come home and I'm like man I
just need five four takes to get that
badge can we just like go around a few
more times or something and yeah it
seems like 95 days should be enough man
give the man a patch right right you
know how much does a patch cost what's
the long as anybody stayed up there the
longest for an American was Scott
Kelly's nearly a year in space is
longest in in a row basically but it is
a Russian that stayed up there for
longer than a year and he has the
all-time record how and they when they
come back like what is 90 days like
coming back because I've talked to
people who've gone there when they come
back their balances all off the
equilibriums oh yeah you're kind of it's
you're kind of messed up and in your
vestibular system is what's affected the
most
at least that's what's most noticeable
when you first get back actually the
first thing I noticed that let me back
up is how heavy things were again you
know so I like I took off my helmet and
I was holding it in my hand and it felt
like I was holding the anchor to the USS
Nimitz you know that's like I can't my
ever gonna brush my teeth it'd be like
too arduous you know this is your body
severely weakened in 95 days well back
in the day back when I was going there
so that mission my long-term mission was
back in 2008 and back then we were still
losing bone density and muscle mass as
we're going up dead along it about he
lost about one percent of bone every
month so I was about three
loh they don't anymore they don't
anymore because we found out we came up
with better countermeasures to prevent
that what are the countermeasures it's
basically working out and it's resistive
exercise that that does it for you
which we knew back when I was going but
the problem was we had a in that we had
this machine that was kind of a first
generation of the workout machine and it
could do large reps but but low load so
you're doing like a lot of reps at low
weight and and that helped but but what
helps it turns out we didn't we found
this out kind of by happenstance but it
turns out that high load low reps works
much better hmm and so we got this new
machine that you could really crank it
up to 11
and the guys now that that are working
out on that thing are coming home with
no muscle muscle or or bone loss at all
wow that's that's right because whoo
what's the Canadian gentleman that we
had on yes Chris Hadfield when commander
Hadfield came back he I believe he said
it took him a whole year to recover yeah
I mean that was still like a nearly it's
still kind of in the early days so he I
don't know which machine he used he
probably did use a new one but overall
it does take to get everything back to
get your full vestibular system back
your sense of balance to get your all
your bone all your muscle back to
baseline it took me a year to get all
that back - Wow
it's kind of like rehabbing from a major
sports injury that's got to be so
strange you know your body just wants to
shrivel up when you're up there because
there's no gravity yeah it's really
interesting because you're it's a it's
an adaptation and then the body's is
incredible so what is doing is it's
realizing hey you know I don't have to
carry my own weight anymore so why do I
need this big bulky skeleton alright
it's like you're becoming kind of like a
fish where you're you're just you're
shedding all the bone density because
you don't have to your body realizes I
don't need it it's like it's like a fish
in water you know the health fish have
very slender bones that's an interesting
way to look at it like a fish yeah Wow
and we fight it by working out and how
often you have to work out every day
every day every day how often how much
time these do schedule two hours now
you're not on the machine for two hours
it's also prepping you
getting changed and you know cleaning up
afterwards but so you're working a good
hour every day was it like a sweat in
space it's weird because what happens is
uh it if you don't notice if you like in
the beginning you don't even realize it
but it's all building up and even
without like if you have no hair to soak
it up it just builds up like this thin
film of water on your head like a
coating of water
aha you don't even notice it cuz it
doesn't run down and then somebody calls
your name you're like yeah and then oh
that's crazy I've never even thought of
that so it just kind of floats off your
body yeah it's like a dog shaking itself
you know and it just goes everywhere so
if you have it on your arm you can kind
of just go and the sweat will go flying
you know your crewmates won't be too
happy with you if you do this a lot but
yeah Wow oh that's is there video of
people doing that in space there's got
to be there should we show so much video
somebody's gonna have done that but so
are you basically doing compound
movements like deadlifts and squats and
things along those lines
yeah functional fitness kind of stuff
we're but and you're focusing on certain
areas so the bone loss comes mostly from
your legs because you're not loading so
so basically our bones need a stimulus
to regenerate and it happens to us every
day so as you walk as you go up stairs
that load that the bones feel the
compressive load is telling the bone hey
make some more hmm now you take that
away and the bone stops making more and
that's the problem people say like can't
you just think like calcium pills but
it's not a mineral deficiency it's just
there's no load that's interesting the
the body adapts so quickly
yeah the ninety days it has such a and
if you didn't do anything for ninety
days at all you'd be in real trouble
right
yeah that's what's really kind of freaky
is thinking about like well what if we
don't fight this because all these
adaptations you go through are not a
problem when you're in space it's only a
problem if you want to come home right
right losing that bone even like not
using your vestibular organs anymore
your semicircular canals your otolith
organs
you're not making use of those for your
balance you're just going purely on the
visual but that doesn Ischl even make
you kind of sick you get kind of it's
like being airsick
seasick but once your body adapts you're
fine so the question is like what would
we become if we didn't fight it what if
we just went with it and stayed up there
building a water balloon what would you
become right you'd become actually the
place I think in science fiction that
gets it the most correct is if you watch
the the expanse ever watch that show no
I heard it's a really good show I never
got into it though it's good and they
get it right because they show people
like these belters that live in partial
gravity like their whole lives and they
have much slip more slender bones and
like they catch this like terrorist guy
and they want to torture him and all
they do is I make him stand up in
gravity and unearth and it's incredibly
painful for him and uh oh wow yeah that
would probably be what would happen and
it must take a long-ass time to get
everything back if you went from earth
gravity to the space station and you
lived up there for a year and didn't do
anything about it and then came back to
earth you'd basically be like it would
be hard to crawl right yeah you would
yet you're you all you're if you don't
try to fight it the vestibular stuff
would come back probably about the same
rate but well you would be really
hurting with your muscle atrophy and
your bone so you wouldn't you would lose
a lot of your skeleton if you're up
there for a year and did nothing and you
would also you're all your muscles that
you don't use like in your legs and your
postural muscles so you lower back
you're not using those anymore so they
were just like waste away to nothing
you'd be okay in your arms because
you're doing everything you're
everything you do is with your arms
that's how you move that's how you get
around is by pulling and pushing but you
don't you know there's no walk in
there's no stairs
there's nothing does it affect the way
you think at all you know some people
describe a kind of an issue with
short-term memory they call it like
space brain is that a small group of
people that would understand what you're
talking about there I got spray spray
bro I got that too oh yeah so it's
something that I never really noticed it
but I don't know how much of that is
real and how much it's like like you're
freaking out because you're in space
right so it's distracting and maybe you
forget like what then
was you're supposed to remember but mmm
you know like if you're really in the
middle of something and you're all
excited and or and and and you kind of
can't remember somebody's phone number
it's kind of like kind of like that oh
okay so it's just well I would imagine
that just being up there breathing that
recirculated air it's gotta be odd right
yeah and it might stink but I don't know
because the other thing that happens is
you have this big fluid shift so right
now we have a lot of blood pooling up in
our legs and our heart it's most
important job of course is to feed the
bringing oxygenated blood and then when
you take the gravity vector out of the
picture the heart sends too much up to
the brain
and the stuff doesn't collect in our
legs anymore and it all shoots up here
and you get to shift of all that blood
volume to your upper body and your head
gets all puffed up whoa yeah like my so
my first night in space I went to sleep
which is kind of hard to do cuz you're
in space you don't want to go to sleep
right yeah and on that first night I
woke up in the middle of the night I
could have sworn I was standing on my
head doing a headstand or a handstand
I'm like why am i standing on my head in
my sleep this is strange
right and then I looked at the one that
saw the earth I'm like oh that's right
I'm in space yeah so all the blood was
just kind of pooling in your head yeah
is if you like hanging by gravity boots
or something it feels exactly like that
Wow and then after a day - you get used
to it and it doesn't bother you anymore
but you feel congested because you still
have all those volume up here so your
sense of smell and your sense of taste
are all dead end Wow Wow
it's kind of like yeah so it's kind of
like when you have a cold and you in in
your sense of smell and your sense of
taste our leg not as strong so it's like
that all the time that's why we take we
cover we have every hot sauce known to
humankind upon the space station we like
sriracha we got you know Louisiana Cajun
fire sauce and all whatever we got like
a whole stockpile of it because you pour
that on everything so you get some taste
because otherwise everything tastes
really bland oh wow now what are you
eating up there
that's terrible is it freeze-dried foods
mostly er but yeah you don't go for the
food alright this is not like a foodie
holiday so you get basically two choices
you have the American food which is
essentially MREs like military
freeze-dried irradiated you know
infinite shelf life kind of stuff and
and then the Russian food is also based
on their military rations but from
submarines and the Russian food actually
tastes better but the problem is one a
presentation because it comes in cans so
you get these these cans and even though
it tastes good you open that can up and
you look at it it's like God looks like
dog food there's like congealed and yeah
but it tastes it tastes better but it's
just like so unappetizing when you open
that can happen you know it's just not
it does what would happen if you brought
fresh things up there would they would
they rot at the same rate that they
would rot in America yeah the thing is
we have no refrigeration oh we didn't
when I was there they actually have a
small refrigerator now so you can't have
anything that needs to be refrigerated
but you would usually like for the first
couple days we take a bag of fresh food
and we took like sandwiches and and and
fruits and vegetables and stuff and then
because that's the last time you're
gonna have it after that's all gonna be
this the stuff in the packets that you
add water to now when the first day you
actually got up there was that the first
time you had ever been in space on my
first mission yeah the first yeah the
first time in space so your first view
of the Earth from above yeah was that
right there what is that like Wow
well I didn't see it right away because
I was in the mid-deck the downstairs of
the shuttle and there's only one window
down there and it's in the corner okay
so it's in the hatch and it's like the
size of a dinner plate and I was up
there you got a lot of work to do when
you as soon as you get up there so I'm
working like crazy and after about 30
minutes I see this pale blue glow coming
from that window and I'm like
that's the earth you know I should have
a look at that and I was super excited
for this you know so I wanted to be
ready so I pause I close my eyes I
meditated you know call it whatever you
want
I just got ready and when I felt like I
was ready I floated up to that window
and I opened up my eyes and I gazed out
for the very first time at the earth
from space and what that felt like is is
really really hard to describe in words
but if I had to pick one word to
describe what it was feeling at that
moment it would be me really just man
just man I mean it was alright it was
pretty it had a lot like those earth
colors like blues and greens right but
man we've all seen pictures of the Earth
from space okay I mean we got like HD
video coming down from space now where
it's just spectacular you could see
stuff in that video that you can't even
see with your own eyes like like the
aurora and all that hmm and I'm sure
like John Glenn and and like Yuri
Gagarin had no idea what to expect and
so when they looked at and I saw the
earth they freaked out you know and it
was amazing and it was beautiful but it
was it was underwhelming I guess my
expectations are so high mmm like I felt
like there should be like some heavenly
choir and that we should all hold hands
I think yeah yeah most people that have
done it they talk about this realization
that you like this inescapable
realization that we're all on this thing
together and that all these boundaries
of civilizations and cultures and
countries and continents are all
nonsense we're really just all on this
one thing together yeah they call that
the overview effect mmm and a lot of
guys come back and talk about that and
they really feel it and they talk about
a world without borders and you know and
it's a beautiful sentiment and and I
don't I don't want to knock that in any
way but cuz like really a whirlwind up
what you expect to see expect they look
damaged and I dotted lines between a
really
you know I guess it you do you it's
inescapable when you look down and you
see the planet and you realize that
we're all in the same boat you know but
that didn't strike me as a sudden
realization because I think it's because
I knew that before I went you shouldn't
have to go and strap into a rocket and
blast off and look at the earth another
basically we're all human beings I think
I mean I think the things that unite us
are so much stronger and more important
than the crazy little things that divide
us like race or sex or nationality or
politics or whatever and and you at the
end of the day we have this one home and
and we're all stuck here in it together
so I had that strong knowledge before I
went and maybe that's why when I look
down I'm like yeah there it is okay I
get it mmm but it wasn't like all of a
sudden like that the the shade was
pulled back then there's like suddenly a
new realization about like well is there
one place that's the spot on the space
station to get the view well you really
got a big window there's this huge
window called the cupola that wasn't
there in my first mission but it was
there my second mission I got to see it
the second time they added a window yeah
a window the space station yeah you just
you know get there you know it's a it
made it a whole module no had this
cupola which is like as that it right
there so what you look into that's
exactly it yeah so this that's pretty
tight
it's like a it's a dome and so you get a
full 360 view and it's spectacular Wow
and we tell the guys that don't get to
do a spacewalk that this view is just as
good as doing a spacewalk but it's not
it's not it's not but don't tell them
because it it makes them feel better
they're gonna listen yeah
what is the spacewalk like man well
first thing I tell you that the
likelihood of me doing the spacewalk was
like slim to none when I first got there
they tell you that when you
to become an astronaut to go talk to
some of the other astronauts and so I
went in there and we had this
presentation about space walking and it
seemed like to be the like the ultimate
experience just an incredible thing and
I wanted to do it bad so I went I'm
talking to this one astronaut who's a
pretty tall guy those who they can't
tell from the podcast I'm five four okay
so I'm not like not like a real towering
individual a little vertically
challenged I guess and I'm talking to
this real tall astronaut and I said you
know I just heard about this space
walking sounds awesome I want I've been
living in California I've been doing
like some rock climbing some scuba
diving maybe that makes me a good
candidate to do a spacewalk and this
tall astronaut looked at me
like right in the eye he laughed in my
face he said what are you four foot what
a rude I know my first thought was you
know I thought astronauts were supposed
to be polite and this guy like was not
being nice but he was he was actually
just being brutally honest you know it's
kind of tough love and he was like
listen the suit is one size fits all
you're gonna get in that thing and it's
gonna swallow you up and you're not
gonna be able to anything you're gonna
be useless so this is impossible forget
about it so I was kind of pissed off but
but I wasn't gonna let this guy stop me
right so I get there I got the job and I
go down for my first training exercise
which was in this huge pool we got in
Houston and it's like it's a hundred
feet wide 200 feet long 40 feet deep and
we can fit like most of the space
station in there and they get a crane
that comes by they put you in the suit
which weighs you know something like 175
pounds and stuff with the and then in
addition you you're in it too it picks
you up and they plop you in the water
and you float around it's kind of like
being up in space and that's how we
train so get down there's my very first
exercise and I could tell in the first
five minutes of this training exercise
that big tall astronaut that laughed in
my face was right I was not I was
how is that was not doing well I was I
was screwing up I was like it just
wasn't going well why do they make a
one-size-fits-all suit it seems they
have the ability to alter the arms and
the legs a little bit and they have it's
actually three different sized upper
torsos there's a there's a medium a
large and an extra large but that said
it's limited and because it costs a lot
of money to make different sizes so
there's only the gloves that can tailor
because that's actually the most
important thing but I'm I'm getting my
butt kicked you know and I and I got a
needs improvement which is a NASA nice
way of saying you failed right but I
wasn't ready to give up I went and I
knew I was going to need help so I
talked to the people to make this suit
and they did some of those things they
like they shortened up the arms they
fixed it up a little bit for me and then
I talked to the trainers and we said
okay yeah we got to think outside the
box here if we give you the standard
procedure you're gonna be at a
disadvantage but maybe we change your
body positions instead of going straight
on to the worksite maybe we come at the
worksite from the side so you get more
reached that way and we start working at
it and we got better and better and the
end of the story is that I got to
eventually I got the highest possible
qualification to do the most complicated
spacewalks we do and I ended up doing
three different spacewalks so of course
my career and that big tall guy they
laughed in my face you didn't get to do
any yeah you get for talking [ __ ] sir
look at you out there yeah that's me
now what is that feeling like because
it's got to feel insane when you're
strapped to a space station that's
floating around and you're just hanging
by a cord yeah well you're holding on
tight okay and it you do have that
safety tether that you see there and and
you know they can prepare you for
everything except for the visual so when
you like are in the pool you're staring
at the pool wall when you get up there
and you see the whole earth below yeah
some people go out there and get like a
sense of fear of falling of course you
if you let go you're not going anywhere
the space station is moving 17,500 miles
an hour but so are you
so it's kind of like doing the wing wing
walking on an airplane but with no air
to blow you off the wing so when you
look at the space station is rock solid
but you look down and some people get
the fear of falling and then they hold
on real tight which is a terrible
terrible mistake because we call it
space walking but you're not walking
you're doing everything with your arms
so you can wear your arms out exactly so
now if you're climbing and you get like
kind of totally thrashed in your
forearms and now you get that claw hand
and it's useless yeah you can do that
and you got like seven and a half hours
that go and that's bad so so you're out
there for seven and a half hours yeah
with your tepee diaper diaper yeah
poop as well try to avoid that do your
best
I as a as a scientist I had to
experiment right of course so during a
training exercise I waited to like the
very end just in case you know and I let
one go right before they pulled me out
of the pool one day and I resolved never
ever to do that again is that number one
or number two year or two oh boy number
one there's no big deal yeah save that
project oh I could have told you what
was gonna happen
that's disgusting and you're doing in
the pool - you're not doing it an actual
space space yeah to be one of the rare
people that it's actually pooped in
space would be very interesting that's
it that's you know we keep all these
records I don't know who's got that
record it's not me I / yeah
so you just have to let it go when
you're up there yeah so what it what are
you doing when you're out there so if
you're doing seven and a half hours
worth of work you're basically doing
maintenance so it's kind of like being a
mechanic or a technician the way I
describe it but the suit is like so hard
it restricts everything you do because
it's blown up to about four pounds per
square inch and so even just closing
your fists takes work because the the
suits like a balloon and wants to stay
like this and so just closing your
fingers is is takes effort and over
seven and a half hours that gets really
fatiguing you're moving your arms
everything is and
the suit can only move like you can't do
this right you can do this maybe so your
your your ability to raise up your
shoulders is really limited so you're
trying to do all this work but you're
working inside this suit and I describe
it as like it's like trying to change
the oil in your car while wearing a
medieval suit of armor it's hard what
what kind of maintenance are you doing
on the outside of the spaceship
you know we're cleaning the windows
getting the bugs off and like no oh yeah
that that's another and this particular
spacewalk we're assembling a robot that
we took up there but we did other things
like we put a new antenna on top of the
space station we swapped out a bunch of
batteries that were getting old
did you know stuff like that that's
fascinating so you have to you have to
have some real understanding of
mechanical things as well yeah I mean
you're putting stuff together yeah
exactly I mean you it really helps to
have some kind of mechanical aptitude I
mean a lot of us like working on our
cars or building things in our garage
hobbyist kind of stuff we actually
started right out as I was leaving NASA
which was back in 2010 we saw up like
kind of an informal program where we're
we were like going over each other's
garages and doing car repair stuff just
to get more hands-on experience with
that kind of thing so when like say if
you have to do an antenna up there is
that something you're trained for on
earth in the pool and then you go up
there and do it during the shuttle days
absolutely everything we did was
choreographed down to like exactly where
I'm going to put what what handrail I'm
going to put my toolbox on I mean
everything is all figured out in advance
but nowadays and sometimes on space
station even when I was there when
things break you don't have the luxury
of training that for if we're gonna do a
shuttle mission we're doing a really
complex spacewalk we'll do everything
we're gonna do in space at least 10
times in the pool first but these days
you don't have that luxury if something
breaks and you you brief a brief it you
talk about it you you you have some
powerpoints and then you're out the door
and you got to go do it so how much
briefing and how many powerpoints the
training that goes on prior to one of
these unscheduled DBAs is you know
typically on the order of like a day's
worth of
all told so are these powerpoints
pre-loaded onto the space station and
you get it or they have to beam it up to
you
it depends on exactly what your what
you're doing so we identify like the
most likely and most serious things that
could go wrong and we practice those in
the pool and we have all those
procedures suitcase before we ever go
but then sometimes you get a surprise
you know sometimes something breaks you
weren't expecting the break or breaks in
a certain way or there's a complication
that you weren't planning on and then
you gotta improvise
wow that's got to be crazy because I
mean and you're probably doing things
that other people on the space station
maybe haven't done so there's no one
that can tell you hey I did it's no big
deal yeah but you know even if you're
doing something that you rehearsed 10
times and you think you got it all
figured out you still get surprised when
they actually get up there the big one
that I remember is on my second
spacewalk we're connecting this dish
antenna and had to go on top of this big
boom like a big pedestal and there was a
connector that had an electrical
connector and we had like an hour or so
to connect the thing and without it
connected it wasn't getting any power or
data to that antenna and it could get
too cold
and this gazillion-dollar antenna could
be a worthless hunk of junk if you take
too long you're on the clock because
when it was in the shuttle it was
plugged in it was getting its heaters
were on and now you got to plug it back
in and get the heaters back on in a
certain amount of time and so ok we
planned this we train this we get up
there and the clinic there's won't go
together like it doesn't fit and these
two pieces of equipment sat next to each
other for like a year in Florida you
know like a warehouse and nobody thought
well oh maybe we should make sure this
thing Oh No yeah and we got that like it
doesn't fit and we're like crap you know
what do we do so we're shoving and we're
shoving so hard we're pushing understand
so hard that the guys inside the space
station said they feel the space station
shaken like that's how hard we're trying
and then we see little metal shavings
come off and one of those they can get
into connectors were like that's bad so
we stopped and and then and then this
was like kind of my my big hero moment
you know I can a movies they like Brad
Pitt saves the solar system and stuff
you know this is my thing all right
it's not that exciting but I thought I
had this idea said hey the problem we
were basically having was that the
female side was too small and now so I
was too big for it to fit together so I
said to the one of my crewmates inside I
said hey how long til the Sun comes up
because you know it takes 90 minutes to
go around the earth and every 45 minutes
the Sun is either coming up or going
down so it can't be that long and he
goes actually about 10 minutes because
we're behind the earth and it was dark
and then in 10 minutes the Sun was going
to come up and make perfect so I took
the the the female side arms I'm sorry I
took that I took the male side and I
held it in my glove okay and I put it
behind the structure wait I knew the Sun
was going to be coming from here so I
put it in the shadow and I waited for
the Sun to come up and it hit the female
side and the temperature difference if
you're in the Sun or in the shade is I
can be up to like 600 degrees Fahrenheit
difference so I let the Sun hit it and
warm it up and I took the male side
quickly out of my my insulated hand and
away from the shadow and I slid it in
and went right in Wow and that was it
save day so you just deduced this just
understanding how things change
according to temperature yeah thermal
expansion Wow
yeah yeah that's my thing did you yell
to people manufactured it no we're so
happy we have video this you can and
we're we're going woohoo give each other
high fives in the suits we were doing
like it was a victory that's a great
victory though there really is that you
figured that out yeah a lot of people
would have been stuck up there how the
[ __ ] didn't no one try it before they
went up there I don't know maybe they
did and it's just like maybe they
weren't when it got up the space and
experiences different temperatures it
expanded differently I don't know for
sure but so I'm not pointing any fingers
but it didn't work and but we solved it
and that's that's the kind of thing that
you can't like until you have AI or
something that can really learn you
can't code that so that's a real benefit
that humans bring to the equation being
able to do to be able to adapt to
something you didn't
otherwise that thing would have been
junk yeah for robots doing it you're
stuck it's gonna keep pushing it's not
gonna you know you're not gonna be able
to program it now that feeling that you
were talking about of looking out the
window where it was kind of math and
then the difference between that and the
spacewalk is that where you get this
real sense of being in space above the
earth the spacewalk you can't yeah it
that's breathtaking because you have
this helmet that's like a giant fishbowl
and you know after a while you kind of
forget that it's there and you're just
like it's like you know the old Superman
with Christopher Reeve when he's like
flying around the earth and he's just
like in his underwear or whatever yeah
it's like that because you forget like
if you ever have gotten scuba diving and
you get to the point where you just kind
of forget you have the mask on I've
never scuba dive I've only snorkelled if
you spend a lot of time down there you
can get to the point where you kind of
like forget that you're that you're in
it this alien environment and it becomes
like you become one with it mm-hmm and
that's just a wonderful thing well
you've done underwater exploration as
well mm-hmm yeah what have you done
there I live for two weeks
in the bottom of the sea Wow Jesus just
you saying that two weeks at the bottom
of the ocean yeah how deep it was
exactly twenty thousand millimeters
under the sea is about 60 feet which
works out to be about no only 60 feet
that's yeah that doesn't freak me out
too much I thought you're gonna select
miles no I'd start panicking no it's
about 60 feet but but the cool thing was
we stayed there for weeks Wow now if
you're normal if you're normally scuba
diving and you go down 60 feet you have
60 minutes and then you got to come back
up or you get too much nitrogen in your
blood and you're gonna get bent right
mm-hmm so so we if you but it's not a
problem if you just stay the problem is
then if you stay you build up all that
nitrogen in your blood now you can't go
back up so like if you run out of air or
you lose sight of your buddy or
something you can't go to the surface
because within a couple hours you'll be
dead Wow so you have to stay down there
and we use cave diving techniques that
we did a lot of training for
to be safe and we have redundant tanks
redundant manifolds redundant regulators
and we could head valves that we can
flip around so we can always make sure
we can get air without ever having that
in an emergency ever having to come up
because coming up it's not an option so
how do you eventually get out
it's a freaky thing it takes a better
day and what you do is you take so we're
living in this habitat and it was kind
of like a submarine on the bottom of the
ocean but it didn't have a motor so just
like stuck on the floor like a big like
a big cylinder and it had a hole cut in
the side here and and the only thing was
keeping the ocean out was the air
pressure inside whoa
kind of like taking a cup and flipping
it over putting it in a bathtub and
trapping the air and you just scuba dive
on down and then you swim into that
thing and then if then once you pop up
in that hole it's like you're in a
swimming pool inside the habitat and
then you just step out into the habitat
whoa have you ever seen the movie the
abyss yes it's like this like that oh
yeah
how accurate is that movie I think
what's a guy was a Navy SEAL in there he
just like like that's crazy from the
geese legs like what they call that deep
dementia or something is that fake yeah
that's big so this process of getting
back to surface level how you said it
takes a day what do you have to do so he
do is you close up that hole and you
convert the habitat into a pressure
chamber and what you do is we very very
slowly bring the pressure back to sea
level so you decrease the pressure and
you slowly as if you're slowly slowly
going up in the water column and then
over as you do it gradually that the
nitrogen slowly comes out of your blood
and you could feel it kind of tingles
Wow over the course of a day just lie
you tried to lie still in your bunk and
just like read a book or something in
there but you feel like this tingling
and then after about a day of that they
get you all the way back to sea level
slowly so that the nitrogen what you
know it is it's like if you take a can
of soda and you shake it up if you open
it and you know um the top quickly right
but if you open the top really slowly
and he let it slowly come out
don't get all the bubbles right it's
that same effect ah that's a that's a
great analogy yeah oh what's freakier
being in the bottom of the ocean or
being up in space up in space is more
surreal
yeah because the de floating the earth
out the window the views are better but
being it down there was pretty well too
I remember once we're doing this
experiment where I had my crew mate and
had an ultrasound and we're doing this
telemedicine experiment so there were
these docks in Houston looking at the
screen but there was a delay and I was
supposed to find her kidney and I'm like
searching around for a kidney and then I
look up and I look out the window and I
see a six-foot hammerhead shark right
out the window and we have a guy in the
water and I was I and I dropped a giant
f-bomb like wow you know and and all the
all the docs in Houston are freaking out
too thinking like in a moment thing to
see her liver explode on the screen or
something and like what's that what has
a patient has a patient like patients
fine got a six-foot hammerhead
yeah that's got to be really weird right
you're you're in that thing in their
world for how long two weeks yeah so is
that the weirdest animal that you saw is
the hammerhead the scariest thing I saw
was one that I was taking a dump
true story I the way you do this okay
number one you just pee in the pool okay
but if you have to go number two you go
into the pool cuz yous gonna you don't
want to floater in your pool right
that's of course like Caddyshack you
know what that right so what you do is
you go you don't take a tank you just
take your mask and your fins you go down
naked you can we had a we had a mixed
gender crew so I wore some trunks but
you know and you just go down and you
have to swim I don't know it's like
maybe 10 15 feet it's not that far and
there's what we call the gazebo which is
just a little dome that has air inside
now you're out in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean like with no tank no in
you're 60 feet down it's night you can't
see a thing
alone in the ocean but you can see this
little gazebo you swim to that you pop
in and then you got air into some valves
you let in some fresh air and then you
hold on and you just and you take off
your trunks and you just let her rip but
the problem is the fish get accustomed
to this oh Jesus yeah so they go there
knowing that you're gonna poop as soon
as you drop in the water at night it's
like the dinner bell going off it was
like school yeah yeah because this is
feeding time
woah until you feel them like yeah
pecking at the backdoor the worst are
the angelfish cuz that shape they can
get like right up in there oh boy so you
take your fin off and you're like
whacking them oh Jesus Christ
so that's all bad enough but like but as
you're doing that and you're in the
pitch-black Atlantic Ocean 60 feet down
no scuba tank at night at night Oh with
the sound of the ocean like like lapping
against the dome and you're looking down
and this endless black you know just a
black void and you're thinking about
every single scary ocean movie like jaws
you know the meg or whatever they abyss
all those scary movies right and you
think about all those things that could
be down there it can't help but going
through your head so it's kind of freaky
and then you finish and you put your
mask back on and I took a big breath and
I went down and I opened my eyes and my
in my mask in the darkness with my
flashlight and I saw like right in front
of me this huge eyeball like about the
size I don't know of a of a saucer you
know like this big staring unblinking
great at me and I freaked out I just
tore off for them for the pool for the
moon pool and the habitat I jumped in
there I surface I'm screaming I'm
screaming and my crew come running with
a guy like I've been bit by a shark or
something and I'm like giant fish and it
wasn't it was a Goliath Grouper oh I've
seen those things before their enormous
size
a cow it's like hundreds and hundreds of
pounds right yeah yeah oh my god yeah
scared to live in hell at me yeah those
things could literally eat a person yeah
it it was big enough that's for sure
and so it was just decided it scared the
heck outta me like so where were you
were in the Atlantic yeah how far away
were you from like Florida like where
yeah we were just off the coast of Key
Largo okay because that's what I'm
saying like they live down there yeah
well that's an enormous fish man huge
I've seen videos of people catching them
off of boats and it seems surreal look
at that yeah there you go
yeah it's like a giant largemouth bass
that's what it's like if you go bass
fishing they're so similar to bass like
in the way they look
yeah and now imagine like Jesus Christ
look at that yeah imagine that being I
died with that thing in the middle of
the dark Atlantic and no scuba tank
they're delicious to it but like I don't
know if they taste as good as regular
grouper I had yeah I wasn't good so you
get a different he was a good fighter
look at the mouth on that thing
good lord I'll tell you another quick
story about down there so I went out for
a night dive once and I spent the
beautiful thing about saturation diving
like this is you can do basically
infinite time bottom time you're not
limited to like 60 minutes you can stay
out there for six hours you know
whatever so I was not doing this night
dive and I found this beautiful shrimp
it was just spectacularly gorgeous it's
like translucent you could see through
it you see its organs move like internal
organs like doing their thing and I
stared at it for at least like an hour
just helmet light on it and just sat
there and stared at it and it was really
beautiful and I come back inside the
habitat I'm kind of hungry and the best
space food we got is shrimp cocktail and
I flipped that thing off the shelf and
I'm like oh that looks good then I'm
like no I can't do it I can't do it you
felt bad saw the shrimp Wow
I did the next day the next day yeah but
that for that day though you really felt
bad I feel bad mmm Wow
grouper you too felt bad like a nice
grouper sandwich
it's scary I would've been okay with
because it was yeah wonder if they've
ever eaten people because it seems like
they could I mean they swallow giant
fish it seems like if you're not a large
person they might be able to just suck
you right in there you know say now if
this happens to me again I'm gonna be
even more freaked there I feel like I've
read that grouper have bitten people
before yeah like probably trying them
out like if they get hunk you're that
big you probably have to eat so much
yeah this non-stop yeah buffet for those
guys and yeah so when you're down there
and you're doing all the swimming you're
using a rebreather no we're using tanks
regular scuba tanks and what is the
capacity these tanks like how long can
you stay down just swimming around for
we have two and we can isolate them in
case one of them springs a leak but you
don't have that much more time than a
standard scuba tank but we have is
refill stations all around the floor
with high-pressure hoses so we have
these quick disconnects on our system
that you can plug in and fill it right
back up and then you get to go for you
know another couple hours so when you
swim to go take a poo you have to do
that you have to wear the tank or do you
just hold your breath just hold your
breath you're not gone that far how far
you going yeah 15 feet or so in total
pitch-black yeah there's a light on the
gazebo but that's all so you see that
light out there and you know if you get
to there that's where you're pulling
yeah good lord
yeah Wow that's got to be so strange
yeah
what was it like to get back from that
I've probably fill it seems like it
would be real similar to getting back
from space yeah it is the thing about it
the way it makes us such a great
training exercise psychologically is if
you had to get to a hospital
it takes about the same time from that
habitat as a would from the space
station in both cases it takes about a
day I think the space station you got to
get in the Soyuz you got to put your
spacesuit on you got a detach the Soyuz
from the space station you got to
separate from the space station got to
do a deorbit burn you got a land the
helicopters got to come get you by time
all that's done it's like a day and the
Soyuz is a Russian craft yeah so we have
to use Russian crafts
back from the space station right now we
have to use Rachel craft to go and come
back how weird is that
it's not cool what happened all right
so it's not good none of us are happy
about this but what happened was the
shuttles the shuttle let me just say
this is a magnificent flying machine
I mean what's really remarkable if you
go down to like the California Science
Center and you look at endeavour we
design that thing in the 70s like it
doesn't even have a microwave it's got a
conventional convection oven Wow so it's
like ancient technology that the flight
computers on that thing your your Apple
watch could run circles around them I
mean it's like nothing there they're so
primitive but but it did it took off
like a rocket and landed like an
airplane you had you could carry people
you carry the Hubble Space Telescope in
a trunk you can do a space walk from his
has a robot arm that you see there
yeah there's endeavour so that's my
flight actually that's sts-123 in the
middle that's the robot that we put
together Wow but but anyway the it's an
incredible machine and we'll never
design anything like it maybe ever again
certainly not anytime soon so despite
its technological in incredibleness for
lack of a better word it had a couple
key limitations one was it's not that
safe you know so we lost two of them
Challenger in Columbia and we could talk
about that I knew I knew the guys in
Columbian that was really really rough
and then the second thing was a super
expensive because it took so much
maintenance even though it was reusable
or most of it was it took so much
maintenance it took a standing army to
keep it running we're spending I think
three or four billion dollars a year on
the program and and there's no way if we
wanted to build something that was gonna
be more cost effective or safer there's
no way we're going to get a plus up from
Congress so like an addition of four
billion dollars a year to go do that the
only way really to make it happen was to
stop flying the shuttle so he we took a
very painful decision and we said okay
we're gonna retire these things so we
can make something new and we know that
there's going to be a gap
period where we're not gonna have
anything and it's gonna suck but the
good news is is Annie that the great
timing about this conversation right now
is that gap ends this year really yeah
2020 is when that painful period is put
to rest and what what happens we're
gonna have the spacex dragon space X
dragon yeah it's a great name yeah I
love it yeah we're gonna have a brave
new ship and not only a dragon we're
gonna have the Boeing Star liner and and
then we have two other private companies
that are gonna be launching people this
year yeah it's incredible these four
companies all trying to put humans into
space with private companies yeah and
the schedules are just aligning so it's
all looks like it all will happen in
2020 now there they've done some people
civilian trips up in the space right
they have and that's all happens because
by paying the Russians that's what it is
all right yeah why is their equipment so
much better it's not the it's the only
game in town once we once we retired the
shuttles there was nothing else
available I would be like hey um how are
you guys maintaining these things yeah
what are you doing like tell me tell me
what's your maintenance schedule it's
been a little scary lately because I've
had some they've had some mishaps right
like what well we had a launch goes
squirrely where the rocket didn't work
right and handed that a punch off Nick
cake was the American on that
unfortunately he was fine he went off I
mean II eject yeah oh [ __ ] yeah that's
something you want to like do for fun so
during launch yeah so you're launching
Shh no like this is not good yeah when
it when it has these beside boosters
uh-huh and one of them got stuck it
didn't come off right and they were
starting to spin out of control and then
they punched out oh my god how far how
far up are they when they punch out
that's it so we say punch out or punch
out punch out John abort you say abort
okay but I don't in that case I don't
know the exact out to do they were
fairly high they were probably I think
they were still in the atmosphere so I'm
guessing it I'm guessing something like
40 to 70 kilometers up or so and so they
punch out and abort and then are you in
like a capsule like what are you in in a
capsule and then from that point on it's
kind of like a normal landing if you
survive the giant you know yank I think
they were pulling something like five or
six G's I think when a 20 was separate
or maybe even more that system when they
pulled off and then and then and then at
that point you're falling in the capsule
and then the parachutes come out hmm
and and it from that point on it's kind
of like a normal landing oh the G's got
to be crazy right I've did a flight with
the Blue Angels once oh yeah and I think
we went seven and a half G's or
something like that wasn't that that bad
but it's so weird yeah then you see the
consciousness closing in like an
elevator door you see the blackness on
the sides a soda straw going yes
very weird so that like in space like to
get ejected or I guess actually not in
space in the atmosphere and do you have
to climb into that thing before you can
abort or are you in it already
there's no time it's a it's a rocket and
in that case it's a rocket on the top
that pulls the capsule away from the
booster oh wow
just like we did with Apollo and Gemini
mm-hmm now I'm dragon and also on
Starliner we've got much more advanced
systems that are built into the into the
capsule and so they they they're they
push instead of having a tower up on top
that pulls you away they have engines
down here that that push and fly away
hmm and the nice thing about that is the
tower you actually if you don't need it
you have to you have to throw it away
you have to jettison it but that's kind
of like needing to use your ejection
seat every single time you go for a
flight because if you for some reason if
it doesn't jettison you're dead you
can't get the parachutes up with that
thing stuck up on top so that's like a
failure mode that if you put the engines
down here you don't have to worry about
that mmm plus you carry it with you the
whole time so you could use those
powerful engines to really get quickly
away from the booster like the Falcon 9
if it's having a bad day you can use
even if it's blowing up yeah does it
look like can you pull up the SpaceX
what's it dragon what the crew dragon
prude
dragon well there she is that looks like
something from the future that's the if
that's the test we just did that's an
artist drawing of it but this is the
final big test we had to do before we
actually put people inside and we did
that successfully just a couple weeks
ago oh so what we did was we lit up
those those eject engines there that's
an actual shot yeah
that's insane look at that thing yeah it
looks like a UFO yeah it's crazy in a
rocket went kablooey not that we blew it
up but it started once it's separated
the rocket start tumbling out of control
and it made a giant fireball and is that
normal or expected we kind of thought
that would happen yeah well you were
right we're planning on using it again
there it is so they're there did
separate in from the booster Wow and the
booster went kaboom but the rocket but
it was a I think if I remember right I
think it was a 1.5 kilometers away when
when the rocket went kaboom and it was
fine now when you guys do these test
flights
do they have to anticipate where this
stuff is going to land like where the I
mean yeah all this giant metal with fire
any chute so what as you're launching
you have to take into consideration yeah
what the trajectory is wow that's the
explosion CSX complete successful abort
test launch of Dragon crew capsule Wow
yeah so you have to think about where it
so they have to calculate what speed how
fast the earth is spinning where it's
gonna drop well that's that's why and
theoretically you know you got to be
ready for this any given flight mm-hmm
now this one we knew it was gonna happen
but it could happen any time so you
always that's why we always launch out
over the ocean oh okay
and that's why Cape Canaveral where Cape
Canaveral is because if you look at a
map of Florida
that's the Cape is where Florida juts
out as a little prominence that juts out
to the east into the Atlantic and that
way you can go due east which is
generally what you want to do when you
launch or you can even turn a little bit
north or south and you're not gonna fly
over anybody's house or Disneyland or
anything
and if something goes wrong in the old
days like on the shuttle we actually had
explosives on the tank and air these
dudes these rain safety control offers
officers that would sit with a big red
button oh Jesus
and if they see you going out of control
and you're heading back towards land
yeah boom oh my god what a
responsibility they have we used to go
by before launch and meet those guys
look them in the eye and almost look
like psychos showing pictures of our
family don't get itchy bro don't get it
you had that trigger so give it a potato
it seems like a crazy way to handle it
that the junk has to fall in the ocean
yeah well now the Russians and the
Chinese don't necessarily honor that
they actually the Chinese have dropped
nasty burnin boosters on you know it's
sparsely populated but they still have
dropped these things on like villages
and stuff oh boy they're little less
really concerned about this kind of
thing the [ __ ] in China but in the US we
always so we launch and the reason that
you usually want to launch to the east
is you want to take advantage of the
Earth's rotation to give you like a
slingshot effect mmm because if you go
to the east the earth is rotating this
way it kind of slingshot you into orbit
going with the rotation and that's why
you also might be as close to the
equator as you can because if you're
ever you had the north pole and you
launched East it's not gonna help you
all right but the lower you are towards
it equator and more of a slingshot you
get now did they have to figure out over
time where those things were dropping
did they ever make some mistakes I don't
think is that we've had Rockets blow up
on the pad and do a bunch of damage but
once they're up and out I don't think we
ever in the u.s. anyway had that problem
because we always had the ability to
blow it up
if it's there the red lines and if it
passes the red line you push the button
now it's all done autonomously so you
have GPS monitors on board that
self-destruct if it sees it as going
past the line there's nobody with the
button anymore it's all automatic oh wow
and these boosters that fall into the
ocean do they have them documented like
where they're landing so they know where
these things are scattered out
throughout the ocean they know
approximately and and one cool thing was
probably the most
famous booster that landed then the
bottom of the ocean was Apollo 11 the
Saturn 5 and it was just sitting there
you know as a fish habitat oh wow and
Jeff Bezos with his own out of his own
pocket mounted an expedition and went
and got him got those engines that's
when you know you're a baller yeah throw
some money at pulling the rocket
boosters from Apollo 11 out of the ocean
holy [ __ ] like crazy am I gonna do this
weekend maybe I'll watch a movie or now
no go get those engines look at that
Wow there you go powerful Jeff Bezos and
a hard part was finding the right ones
and they got them as I saw the serial
number they're like yeah look at the
image finding the right ones cuz there's
a bunch down there yeah there was a
bunch of cyber fives
Wow and they found the right ones look
at that that's nuts and perfectly
preserved yeah and then when did he do
this what yesterday night 10 that pushed
Buzz and Neil and my team to them Wow
that's madness yeah what a crazy image
boosters landing in China
oh yeah oh that's what I'm hitting the
ground yes Oh rewinding that again that
is very quick I started right where the
explosion was there's other ones it's
just falling from the sky nighted on
impact with the ground so these people
are just chillin and a giant chunk of
metals falls from the sky oh my god
that's crazy
know that but that's hypergolic fuels so
that's like you don't want to be
breathing that stuff that's pretty toxic
look at it just landed on people like
whoops sorry that's a that's a BRC big
great cloud you know or b.o.b FRC you
know what yeah you know I've been here
that what is in that cloud
it's hydrazine so it's a nto MMH mono
methyl hydrazine and nitrogen tetroxide
it's it's stuff they don't want to drink
look at that falling from the sky oh my
god that's crazy yeah
it fell on a small village China doesn't
give a [ __ ]
they just let it go it is I mean that
those villagers are getting pre unlucky
because it is pretty sparsely populated
so you're just playing the odds but if
we went we wouldn't do that well that
has to be terrible for their breathing
and their health yeah that stuff was
gonna linger right yeah I got we get
into the drinking water
uh-huh I mean it the quantity is of that
are probably not gonna be like absolute
catastrophic either the bigger risk is
getting blown up by it but it's still
not good so why doesn't China adhere to
the same sort of well they do what they
got to do yeah yeah so when when you're
a part of these expeditions and you know
you're you recognize that you're one of
very few people that ever gets to
experience this these kind of things do
you feel like a responsibility to try to
relay this information to people like
yeah it's part of our job you know so
when we're when I was that NASA they
would send us out to do these PR events
and we go to schools and I would go back
to like Jersey where I'm from and go
visit all these school systems and part
of Jersey from my parents are from
Newark and I grew up in pursue my - yeah
yeah I heard about that yeah Parsippany
I know where that is Persephone that's
right that's right career I went to
press seven high school Wow
um and so you go back and try to inspire
kids - yeah - pursue this case same kind
of thing and I still do it so I was just
in Israel last week I just got back two
nights ago actually so every year on the
anniversary of the Columbia tragedy they
have a space week in Israel where they
have a whole bunch of STEM education
events and there's also a technical
conference and then there's a memorial
for the first Israeli astronaut that was
on Columbia Elan so I got to know his
family really well and I go back there
every year and and we had the memorial
last Friday and so yeah I'm still and I
tried it I think I met every school kid
in Israel and got the you know it's good
just try to get them excited about the
future about a bright future you know
well the reason why one the reason why I
brought this up is I saw a video we
talked about how your during your
childhood you got a photo on your wall
of look
at the Earth from the moon the
photograph that was taken yeah and that
that's what set the seed or planted the
seed in your head yeah right so I also I
also go out and I do a lot of you know
public appearances and do motivational
speaking kind of stuff and I talk about
the importance of both inspiration and
determination so I found out when I was
a kid that they were they were taken not
only fighter pilots but also like
engineers and scientists to be
astronauts because I was was totally
super stoked by that the whole concept
of going into space but I had a mom
that's like scared to fly she was
typical Jewish mom she was like she's
like I told her once I wanted to join
the Air Force and she in it like a
public restaurant and she starts
freaking out and like started like
soliciting opinions from the other
parents would you listen
you know the hilarious oh so I never
thought I knew that like being a test
pilot was not gonna happen so I thought
being an astronaut wasn't gonna happen
but then I found out that you could do
it you can be an engineer and be an
astronaut and then like that was my
Eureka moment I was inspired but to be
determined I got that photo and I put it
over my desk and was like that was my
like that was the beacon you know that
was the goal and I kept working and any
time I was having a difficult time I
looked up at that thing and say no one
day I'm gonna hang that in the astronaut
office and Johnson Space Center and I
still have that thing that must have
been surreal the moment when you were on
that spacewalk thinking about your
childhood and thinking about being
inspired by those images yeah he's like
holy [ __ ] I'm actually an astronaut I'm
eeen you really are an astronaut I mean
how many are there
there's there I think there's been
around 500 people that have been to
space ever yeah that's nuts not a lot
and now with SpaceX what is your role
with SpaceX so I left NASA in 2011 and I
went down and met with Elon and I said
hey I really like what you're doing here
can I help and can i and he gave me a
job so I went I left NASA and I came
here and I worked there for seven years
did a bunch of different things
eventually became our director of space
operations so my team was responsible
for operating Mission Control at SpaceX
and controlling we have another Dragon
capsule that we use for cargo to take
cargo and we've been doing that for a
long time up to the space station and
back and so we would operate in Mission
Control but we're also we're designing
then the crew one that we showed you so
we were coming up with the procedures
and all the rules of how we're going to
use that thing and and and meeting all
of NASA's requirements and helping to
provide input to the guys designing the
displays and the suits and the controls
and the seats and all the stuff you need
for people and so that was that was you
know I did that for quiet quite a long
time well what do you have thoughts on
this what what's happening now with
space travel where it's transferring
into the public sector or the private
sector rather instead of being something
that the government handles now it's
private companies is that a good thing
it's a great thing is that yeah because
first of all it's not quite that black
and white in the media it's all
portrayed as commercial space and like
these private companies are taken over
the truth is at least for the human
orbital spaceflight that we're doing at
SpaceX and that Boeing is doing with
with their vehicle it's a part as a
public-private partnership and so NASA
is working very closely with both those
companies and we're working together and
in a way it's not really that different
from the way it's always been you know
like NASA didn't have a NASA factory
that built the Saturn 5 rocket is built
here by like McDonnell Douglas and North
American Rockwell built if I remember
right North American built and built a
command module and and the lunar lander
was built by Grumman so those were all
private companies they're contractors
but they're still private companies and
what's happening now is just a slight
change to the relationship between NASA
and the private companies where NASA is
not micromanaging quite as much as they
used to they're saying ok here's our top
level requirements we want you to get
four people up and down to the space
station that's a bit of a simplification
because actually the requirements
document is like there are thousands of
requirements but they're but they don't
go down and tell you how to meet each
requirement they leave it up to you so
now SpaceX there's a lot more room to
innovate then like North American
Rockwell did when when they built
the vehicles back during Apollo so that
that and the other thing that's
different is that the funding the way
the NASA is paying its firm fixed price
you know all these that like the Space
Shuttle when we build an aircraft
carrier it's it's cost plus contracting
which has been terribly abused and has
been horrible for the US taxpayer it
what it says to the company is you can
it could cost whatever costs that's what
will pay and in fact will give you a
profit as a percentage of the cost so
like you're in it your incentive as the
company's like to make the cost as high
as you can so your profit as high as it
could but that's ridiculous yeah so it's
not cool and and but it they had to do
it that way like during World War two is
when it started because like nobody knew
how much was gonna cost to build a p-51
Mustang because nobody did one before
hmm so they came up with this mechanism
but now it's kind of been abused now
we're using it to do things that we've
done before and then the third thing is
that that the companies own the
intellectual property so what that means
is like Rockwell when they built the
Space Shuttle couldn't like build a new
Space Shuttle like build like Space
Shuttle enterprise or something and then
go sell tickets on it they weren't
allowed to but we can so we can we're
gonna build this dragon we're gonna take
Bob banking and Doug Hurley two friends
of mine are gonna be the first
astronauts that ride it to the space
station and once we meet our NASA NASA's
our number one customer they're paying
the bill so once they are satisfied we
can then go make another one and sell
tickets and take you know private
individuals so really that's the key
difference and I really think that 2020
we're gonna look back at 2020 as it as a
year that everything changed really yeah
because all those dreams of science
fiction I like being able to take your
vacations around the rings of Saturn and
like all the like private space stations
all that kind of stuff that we grew up
hoping would happen when we were older I
think it's really finally starting
because this is this is the beginning of
that infrastructure that that private
sector commercial infrastructure and and
an ability to actually get it done we're
always talking about how
only got the future in like space 1999
that television show I like that show I
said all the time yeah but all those
shows like even I think Blade Runner was
like now right didn't we discuss this
like last year 2019 like we got
everything wrong in terms of what the
timeline was the timeline is totally
wrong but I think that the overall the
overall direction is is right in a lot
of this stuff and we'll get there I
really do believe that if we don't end
up killing each other or have some
horrible catastrophe like asteroid hit
us we're going to end up living in space
and have that kind of Star Trek future I
mean I really think that's our destiny
as long as we don't screw it up man how
far out are we looking at Star Trek Star
Trek might take a while did we get like
warp drive another hundred years and we
got to find those Dively thorium captain
she's predicting hope that like how far
do you think we are like if you had a
wide timeline of like literally being
able to go to another planet well you
know well going to Mars is something we
could do now in a decade if we really
really really want
ilan keep saying that I think he's right
I mean it's it's not a question of
technology the big missing piece I think
in an understanding about what that
would be like is is the effect of
radiation on the human body
there's engineering solutions we could
come up with for that this is for the
prolonged journey the six-month journey
once you start talking about what so so
right now like on the space station I
took a bigger radiation hit than I would
have if I stayed at home but much of
ahead you know the manner dose I took
was not that much it's like like a tenth
of a sievert or something I mean it's
like it was produced receiver a sievert
if you take one sievert then you're
increasing your chance of getting cancer
depending on your age and gender about a
couple additional percent can you
mitigate that with supplements like is
there iodine that you take or something
along those lines there's some you know
maybe antioxidants but I think that
that's that's not a
see it's not gonna fix this problem that
could help maybe they say take iodine
tablets right if you're exposed to
radiation isn't that like something that
they recommend yeah for like for the
nuclear reactors you know and and all
that but I think that protects that
protects function of some one under the
organs I can't remember but it's not
going to solve that's not gonna solve
this problem but you can shield yourself
with anything that has hydrogen in it
it's a pretty good shield so water is
great like when I was on the space
station I put a big water jug around my
head really it just I figured couldn't
hurt and and then like liquid hydrogen
or even plastic that's made just derived
from hydrogen is pretty good shielding
okay so you could have like conceivably
a light plastic suit that you wear that
could shield you from a lot of the
radiation on the way to Mars there's
actually a company in Israel that is
teaming with NASA is gonna fly these
like vests on to try to shield the
people you can also put it in the hull
and or you can have just a storm shelter
because there's basically once when
we're on the space station we're above
all the atmosphere but we're still below
the magnetic field of the earth so we
still getting we still enjoy a lot of
protection from radiation hmm once you
go out of that and you go to the moon or
to Mars then you basically hanging it
out there you're you're not you're no
longer protected by that and so you're
gonna take either GCR galactic cosmic
radiation which is just everywhere out
there sounds terrible it sounds bad that
it GCR galactic cosmic radiation that
sounds really bad yeah yeah those are
that those are ionized that there aren't
that many of them but when they hit you
they can do a lot of damage they have a
lot of energy there's accelerated to
like near relativistic speeds like near
the speed of light and then and then
there's a solar then you gotta worry
about solar flares SPE solar proton
events and those don't come those are
very like I'm predictable well they're a
little bit predictable with sunspot
activity but but they come every once a
while in their giant spikes they last a
couple hours to a couple days and they
could totally fry you
they're even worse oh [ __ ] yeah so
conceivably we could send people to Mars
and halfway there they get cooked yeah
so you have a six-month window where you
have to just roll the dice well so what
you can do is you can have a storm
shelter right at way you put like a lot
of this shielding and then if you could
detect it the the SPE you the GCR is
there all the time but the solar events
you could you can detect them coming and
you have enough warning time to get
everybody into the storm sure how much
time you have
usually when you first start seeing some
of the proton radiation then you start
you have like an hour oh so you got time
going 48 minutes from now it's coming
yeah just like hunker down there
probably grabbing all the water bottles
you can Wow
and depending upon how big the ejection
is you don't know how long it's gonna
last
yeah they could be a different
magnitudes and different discs ill you
even if you have the shoulder the
shielding I mean if it's a really huge
one and and we didn't really have any
capability of defending from it when we
did Apollo and there was a between two
Apollo missions there's one of these big
ones oh boy and we just got lucky that
it was in between so that seems crazy
what a nutty roll of the dice yeah but
again there's there's and we keep
getting smarter about it and and and and
I think you know for like right now we
can send you to Mars and bring you back
and and probabilistically speaking you'd
probably have like an additional four or
five percent chance of developing cancer
over your lifetime which it's not like a
death sentence you know it's a little
it's a little uncomfortable yeah yeah
but we're getting better and and the
thing about it there's two things about
it one we keep getting better
technologies better shielding we can
actually come up with there's ways you
can do active shielding with magnetic
you can create your own magnetic field
around the ship and and and so it always
be like Star Trek with like you know a
force a force field or shields or
whatever so we're there's a ways that
maybe we could do that there's also the
other thing that we don't know we know
exactly what radiation is out there
we don't know exactly what that
radiation does to humans the best we
have to go on is like data from some of
the atomic bomb survivors and and
radiation workers then working like
power plants and stuff to take some dose
but it's a different kind of radiation
so right now the error bars are really
big so when we say they go five percent
chance of cancer that's taking a very
conservative estimate if we can find out
what it really does the humans maybe
it's a lot more benign and maybe we
could sharpen that pencil and say yeah
it's acceptable what if people come back
smarter what if it's like some [ __ ]
x-men type [ __ ] yeah maybe like you know
I mean radiation is always bad in real
life but always good in comic books
yeah spider-man if the Hulk spider-man
is so many superheroes they were
involved in some sort of an accident
wasn't dr. Manhattan wasn't that a thing
with him as well I think so
yeah I think so I don't from The
Watchmen I think he became who he is
because of an accident a document I
believe so yeah and I was hoping that
you know I was up I had my kids after I
did that flight oh so I'm hoping that
they would like one day genius kids yeah
how old are your kids now I got a
nine-year-old boy and a two-year-old
girl notice anything unusual about them
I didn't notice one day the two year old
girl was concentrating on her blocks and
one of them started floating oh man so
what what changes have been made since
you go from the old shuttle model of
that technology to the SpaceX dragon
crew thing probably the single biggest
changes is all the we've gotten a lot
better at electronics and software so
the vehicle is highly automated and
that's why we can fly like like normal
people that don't have like years and
years of training because it's so much
more smarter than the shot of the
shuttle you shouldn't say so much more
smarter so much butter but you're such a
genius you're not supposed to use
language like that you're goddamn
astronaut so much more smarter I'm sorry
though I was a math as though as my
thing that verbal my verbal SATs weren't
that spare
about the you know yeah this is much
more smarter and what about what about
the there was always an issue with the
tiles right with the re-entry time I was
like and then that's that's what did
Challenger and know which one was Olivia
Columbia that's what did Colombian the
the new design have they made advances
and how that stuff is applied or is it a
different surface they use yeah so that
that is something that's also not really
worry anymore that the reason that
Columbia took that damage was it was
foam like the big orange tank that's
behind the Space Shuttle it sticks up
above the space shuttle and some foam
fell off of it we always had some foam
shedding off the thing and in the
beginning we took that very very
seriously as a major problem but the
thing is is this there's this concept of
mmm gonna forget the name of it now well
let me just describe it so so you get
away with something for so long that you
begin it's not normalization of deviance
that's what it's called so it's when you
get away with something for so much so
long it's something that was a deviant
thing or something that was bad it's
treated as a normal thing and that's
what happened to us because we knew that
that foam coming off could do damage to
the Space Shuttle and in the beginning
we tried really hard to do something
about it we treated it very seriously
but it was hard we couldn't really come
up with an easy fix in the meantime were
flying and nothing bad was happening
what was really happening is what we
were getting lucky and then eventually a
big piece came off hit Columbia right in
the wing and it shattered a mint a big
hole inside the wing but nobody knew for
sure and they made a bad decision to not
like investigate it further assumed it
was okay
brought him home and and obviously you
know what happened so it could be
possible to fix something like that if
they had known it could have been
possible we did a lot of things like
when I flew we had a lot of things in
place that to try to fix that one we got
a rid of a lot of the foam that was
unnecessary we tried to do things that
stopped the foam we also had ways of
detecting it so that we would know we
had sensors and the wings we added a
maneuver we do when we fly up to the
space station we did like a
pitchover where we took photographs of
the of the heat shield to see if
anything got hit hmm
so at least we would know and then we
could we could shelter in place on the
space station so there's a lot of things
we can do at the shuttle but the night
the thing about with Dragon and
Starliner and the new vehicles is they
sit on top so there's no any foam that
comes off the rocket is not gonna hit
you so problem solved so that that's one
example of how we don't have to worry
about that anymore
now is the surface different do they
still have the same kind of tiles the
the heat shield it looks like again the
heat shield is that the material on the
side of the capsule on the walls of the
capsule is is made out of silica so it's
it's similar to the tiles but the the
the material that's in the in the heat
shield itself is an ablative material it
means it kind of like as it heats up it
flakes off and it takes the heat away
with it and that's that's kind of more
similar to like it was during Apollo
it's a much more advanced that thing
yeah and they're cool can we see that
could we go there well they give us a
tour I bet we can I bet we could my bail
Apollo no I don't want to see a
spaceship the guy you should ask was my
boss when he was here yeah we're talking
about other [ __ ] no I you know he's got
the keys to the factory but but there
there she is on the launch pad so that
white stuff at the top mmm on the
capsule itself that's kind of like the
same material as the as the time has the
tiles but the heat shown on the bottom
is called pica phenolic impregnated
carbon ablator
so it's a different it's a different
very high-tech material that is really
really good at withstanding tremendous
amounts of heat that heat shield is way
oversized you could use that thing at
least 10 times and it really was
originally designed for actually entries
coming back from the moon when you go in
much faster and you hit you build up a
lot more heat when you hit the
atmosphere I think just coming back from
the space station so ultimately that's
the goal for these things to take people
to the moon to take people to Mars to
take people well and reusable right this
is just a start so reusability is key
and there's elements of this vehicle
that are not reusable that trunk you see
the thing
cylinder below the capsule is not
reusable we throw that away that the
second stage on the Falcon 9 we throw
away and you know Elon hates that with
that the Holy Grail is 100% reusable but
affordable reusability where you don't
have to spend like a gazillion dollars
refurbishing it in between flights
mm-hmm and we're getting there in the
next vehicle is going to be the real
that's gonna be the real hopefully we
will we will get that Holy Grail with
this starship that that we're working on
now so there's a is a top-secret one
that you can't talk about that what it
does you seem hesitant well it's just
you know we got a lot of development
going on and and it's not top-secret I
mean Elon went down did a press
conference in front of it in Texas not
too long ago and it showed what it
looked like yes this is one of the tests
it's called star hopper so this was a
beginning this is a testbed to test the
engine to make sure that we can that's
fake
that's real that's rude that is come on
that is not CGI really that's the thing
that's the thing whoa now the real thing
is gonna look just like that it's it's
it's the a this is really testing the
engine and the sensors and the
electronics what is the jet coming out
of the bottom those are that's that that
the bottom is a is there as a raptor
engine it's burning liquid methane and
liquid oxygen and then those puffs at
the top are cold gas thrusters just to
keep it pointing the right way and so
that's landing now yeah my god that's
amazing
awesome that is a mate look how gently
it lands yeah dude that seems like
science fiction I know that's not
telling you like this thing and I know
that the guys up in Blue Origin - Jeff
Bezos company has got all kinds of
incredible stuff on their drawing board
2020 is this start but it's just a start
show me that again I need to see that
again I need to see other pictures of it
okay that's that I want to see that
thing land again that video of it
landing is crazy I got lucky
did you it's so crazy though the image
to see it gently come down and perfectly
land like look at that man that looks
like some war the
world's type [ __ ] that's in a Tom Cruise
movie right yeah like if they were
flying over earth and they were starting
to land my god that's amazing I remember
when Elin first talked about landing
Rockets on their tails he was like I
think I remember him saying yeah we want
to do it just like Buck Rogers so so I'm
working with with with Ron Moore on this
TV show I'm working on now Wow look at
that thing
I mean yeah it's pretty awesome I said
before people want to see this Jimmy
what is the name of the the video so
people listening can go 150 meters star
hopper test more than two million eight
hundred thousand seven hundred thousand
views that's amazing man two million
eight hundred ninety-eight Wow it's on
the SpaceX page so you can go and check
that out so that's next stage that's net
stakes so there's gonna be a rocket and
then that that thing is gonna sit on top
of it or something like that thing and
then we're gonna get both back the
rocket will land on its tail and then
the same after it goes off to the moon
or even Mars it'll come back and also
land on his tail and then we'll get both
pieces will get 100% back Wow
and then we really got reusability guy
and hopefully we'll be able to use these
one like a hundred times at least now is
there any innovation or any
breakthroughs in fuel and in the type of
propulsion systems that you need me no
dude conceivably is there ever gonna be
a time where we have like a like a Star
Wars ex fighter that can just go shoot
off onto its own you know there's
there's a potential for more advanced
more efficient thrust engines and
probably one of the most promising ones
in the near-term is actually a nuclear
engine a nuclear thermal rocket where
you instead of using combustion to
propel hot gasses out the back of your
nozzle you have to use a nuclear reactor
and you take hydrogen you flow it over
that you heat it up like super hot and
shoot it out the back without lighting
it on fire and if you do that you can
actually get much more thrust at with
much less mass of fuel like a smaller
fuel tank but more thrust over time so
that's one possible way to go so it's
conceivable that one day there could be
a standalone unit that does
need thrusters that eject oh it still
would look like a regular rocket because
the back of the head of the nozzle would
still have like fire coming out the back
but it would just be superheated instead
of letting him and fire to heat it up
you would you would there you go there
we go here nuclear propulsion ntp yeah
nuclear thermal propulsion so the top
one is traditional and the second one's
the nuclear one Wow
yeah that's so it's yeah so alright so
there there it is that's the hydrogen
coming in and flowing over the reactor
instead of having liquid oxygen and
liquid hydrogen then you just all you
need is the liquid hydrogen's Wow so
that's one way but in a short term the
advanced you're sitting there with that
star hopper is that it's still a
traditional chemical propulsion rocket
so it's got fuel and oxidizer which is
liquid oxygen because no oxygen up there
to have fire you need the pyramid right
so you need the oxygen and that fuel and
the spark and you have to bring your own
oxygen if you're in space because you
can't use there you don't have that much
for anymore
so to carry liquid oxygen and some fuel
and in the Falcon 9 for example it's
basically kerosene it's rocket fuel but
it's our p1 but it's basically kerosene
mix what looks like liquid oxygen the
engine you saw in that star hopper is
advanced and different because what it
uses it still uses liquid oxygen but
instead of kerosene it uses liquid
methane and it's actually not as
efficient quite it doesn't have it quite
that the specific impulse which is a
measure of efficiency it doesn't have
that quite as good as hydrogen it's
better than kerosene but not quite as
good as hydrogen but here's a thing you
can make it on Mars and that's why we're
that's why he lands bill in that engine
because you can go to Mars and you don't
have to bring your gas to come home oh
oh so that was the big knock on going to
Mars for the longest time was that you'd
never be able to return you have to you
have to wait two years for the
trajectory for the plans to come back
around so you have a window that come
home so you do it to stay a while but
that the beautiful thing is if you can
go someplace and gas up again fill up
your tank without having to bring all
the gas with you that's huge right you
can you can be so much you can carry
some
much more that way and and that's you
can with a carbon dioxide that's in the
Martian atmosphere and the water that's
in the ice that's on the surface of Mars
you can have a reaction a process by
that allows you to create to take those
two things to make liquid methane and
you can have the tank of that ready to
go and all done robotically you can get
the telemetry back saying we got the gas
and then you go now how much are things
can accelerate now that you have all
these different companies competing
against each other that's what's
beautiful is like the pace of
technological changes like really going
exponential again just kind of like it
was during Apollo so we're back into
that really rapid that fast track we
kind of fell off of that for a little
while and the nice thing about people
ask me like what's the biggest
difference between working in SpaceX and
working at NASA and I would say it's
decision speed because well we'll make
up our mind quickly now the reason we
can do that is we got a tremendous
amount of agility because sometimes when
you make up your mind quickly you make
the wrong decision right yeah but if you
hurry up and figure out that you made
the wrong decision and you have the
agility did then say okay that was not
right let's try something else then it
works at NASA you know we had all these
contractors and suppliers and and a very
cumbersome kind of system that we took a
long time to make sure we made the right
decision because changing things was
prohibitively costly mm-hmm but SpaceX
doesn't have to worry about that oh now
what is the difference between the way
SpaceX is handling it you said Boeing
has something what did they call it
again so nASA has Commercial Crew
program and they selected to commercial
companies to partner with SpaceX and
Boeing and so's Boeing is using you know
an older
rocket that's been around a long time
called the Atlas 5 and they built a
capsule to go on top of that called the
Starliner and so this is strictly for
commercial flights well it mean it's for
its that that the anchor tenant if you
will that the core customer is still
NASA because NASA is going to use both
of these rockets to replace the Space
Shuttle and we won't have to beg the
Russians for rides anymore hmm let me
see what the Boeing one looks like
what's the name of it again a star liner
or used to be called the cst-100
let me see what this sucker looks at
least call it the POS 100 there's
Network meeting but it's a good ride
it's a good vehicle okay so it's kind of
similar in its design a little bit it's
doing it look well looks pretty dope
yeah one key difference is it lands we
splashed down in the water and this one
lands on land with those air bags
oh wow [ __ ] that yeah what if those bags
don't work this was it is it fill up
like the way they use Rovers on Mars
where it's surrounded by these gigantic
air bags and it bounces when it hits the
ground it doesn't bounce because that's
not good for people robots don't mind
but if you bounce like that you're gonna
be really upset so it just hits and kind
of like airbags that deploy in a car and
they deflate and then you're done and so
this is on the same sort of timeline as
the SpaceX ship yeah I think they're
there I think SpaceX aspects is really
ready to go like in March like very soon
but I think we're gonna wait a little
longer because they're talking about
extending the mission for Bob and Doug
and keeping them on the space station so
they need more training sorry Bob alone
yeah well they get they get to hang out
in space for a while I'm not - I don't
feel too bad for them and their
equipment is keeping them from losing
all the bone density and muscle and
everything yeah they'll be fine now when
does Elon go to space oh wow I mean how
well do you have to have the system
working before you put the boss in the
capsule shoot him often in the heavens
he's got a lot of work to do here so I
don't think he's going to anytime soon
but he does eventually when when we get
this up and running he does eventually
want to go he talks about he wants to
die a Mars just not a tactful you know
that the that jokey cos so that's that's
you know he's serious about that he
really does want to die on Mars like
really old he wants to go and live the
rest of his days as part of a permanent
Martian colony Oh
Elon I got to talk to you about this but
he's not going to tell us you always
thought that way yeah that's always been
the plants always been a play maybe we
can get him high again
seems like it's our boy yeah well he's
gonna wait he's not gonna be the first
one he's gonna wait until we have like
pieces
and some catchy no and like in a decent
hotel and so the concept is terraforming
right that is that's not gonna happen I
think even Elon would tell you that's
not gonna happen in his lifetime that's
something that like generations from now
we could think about it's that's that's
hard so there's some sort of domed
civilization like what yeah yeah live in
some kind of pressurized compartment
some kind of pressurized habitat so it
it'd be kind of like science fiction
like what you see in science fiction
things where it's land on planets and
people live inside the ships and you
can't go outside unless you wear a suit
let's wear a suit yeah Wow
but hopefully there'll be plenty of
plenty of room inside if once this thing
grows to be really big we also have to
make sure it's really really well
protected from radiation because even
once you're on Mars you have to worry
about those GC ARS and yeah yeah didn't
he have an idea to like nuke the caps
yeah like nuke the Solar polar caps and
yeah you know it's not like anybody's
really sitting around drawing up plans
for that that was kind of like like if
we had to do it how could we do it
that's one thing you know that came off
the top of his head but what was that
that was to raise the temperature or the
change the atmosphere or that's the like
melt the captain and eject a lot of gas
into the atmosphere and beef up the
Martian atmosphere what a weird roll the
dice that would be and I think we're
gonna be trying that easy and then what
is the concept like in terms of
terraforming what kind of window of time
would it take to turn that into a
livable environment that you're starting
to really extrapolate it out pretty far
and I'd be pretty hard for me to give
you it so there's like giant leaps of
technology that have to take yeah that's
that's a big one but it's as a proof of
concept it's it's sort of I mean there
is a theory right the young can alter
the atmosphere and I mean Mars has got
enough gravity that if you could put
enough gas into the atmosphere it would
stick around mmm kind of like you know
it's it's got its possible you're not
going to get to one atmosphere pressure
like 14.7 PSI like we enjoy here
might be enough now and there their
gravity is what percentage of Earth's
it's about third third Wow so you you
would definitely experience a lot of the
same issues that you have if you go to
the Space Station so if you wanted to go
from Mars back to Earth it would
definitely be some sort of an adjustment
period yeah you know the really
interesting thing is like we know we
have a lot of data we know what happens
at in zero-g
because we have a lot of us have been up
to the space station and Skylab and
mirror and all that and we have tons of
data at 1g because all of us every day
live in 1g we don't really have any data
in between mm-hmm
so the question is is a half a G half as
good or maybe it's like 80% is good
Brian
and and and so is it linear or is it
nonlinear we don't know mm-hmm
and that's why if we send people and we
live on the moon or we go to Mars when
we live on Mars and we have data a kind
of moon it's about a sixth of the
Earth's gravity
so we'll get points in between and then
we can figure out if this thing is
there's a lot of stuff that happens to
you that may be completely solved but
even just a smallest amount of G hmm but
we don't know well that's interesting
right we don't know yeah because zero
G's an issue we don't know how much of
an issue
1/3 G is yeah now what about food like
what are they gonna do with food on Mars
are they gonna have to fly all the
ingredients out everything out would you
start talking about missions that are
that long carrying all your food with
you bringing it all becomes mass
prohibitive you know you just gotta take
so much and that just means you need
that that much bigger of a rocket and
it's just after a while it gets you know
to the point where it doesn't work
what's all the food for the rest of your
life essentially yeah so we're probably
if we're talking about like living for a
long time on Mars or even deep space
missions we gotta grow food so probably
plants hydroponically like the Matt
Damon movie yeah yeah
how realistic was that you know that
movie is really pretty good good movie
yeah there was a I met the author the
guy that wrote anyway
the guy that wrote the book and I told
him that I really didn't like his book
[Laughter]
yeah he's like why was it because like
there's not really enough dynamic
pressure in a Martian windstorm to knock
the antenna off the roof like now it's
fine with that
said it was because we don't have enough
redundancy in the comm system and that's
not really realistic I'm like that no
because well why didn't you like it I'm
like well listen I have a long day of
work at SpaceX I come home I open up the
book before I go to bed and I'm reading
this like okay I got 62 Souls and I got
to cover 3000 kilometres and I've got 52
moles of nitrogen hydroxide blah blah
blah and I'm like it's like I'm still at
work like I wanted some escapism I want
to like go home really have romance now
or something well that's not his fault
though no well so you just busted his
paw busting his balls yeah that's it's
interesting though that he got it close
yeah yeah he did a great job that's all
true I mean for something does he have a
background in that yeah I think he does
uh I hear something okay that makes more
sense yeah yeah but what that movie was
terrifying
the idea that you can get stuck up yeah
the only part of the movie which I don't
think was in the book that was not
realistic at all was when he cuts his
glove and does the Iron Man Thing uh-oh
usually flying back to the spaceship you
can't really control it that he would
spin out of control it's yes you'd also
need a big hole to really get enough
propulsion and then your suit would
deflate I mean it's just that's just not
gonna work yeah and how long would you
survive out there with no suit that's a
good question just holding your breath
just well you can't really hold your
breath because as the as a pressure all
goes down the first thing you have to
worry about is Barrow trauma so like in
your lungs and in your sinuses and
you're it's all gonna like like an
overinflated balloon so if you try to
hold your breath that's a wrong thing to
do cuz you go so you have to let the
breath out yeah you can't really do that
for very long though like the way people
hold their breath underwater they
actually have breath in their lungs yeah
but they're not equalizing what the
pressure as a
go down you know when they do those like
freediving that's right
so if you're gonna equalize you're gonna
have to let the air out or it's going to
just expand and and be extremely painful
and and hurt you so you could do that
but then eventually you get to the point
where the pressure gets so low that the
all the liquid in your tissues starts
turning into gas that's called a Buell
ism and then you'll start getting this
massive swelling like your nickel for a
puff up like that and everything you'll
get grotesque swelling and wherever that
your blood is turning to gas and OH
although all the liquids and your
tissues are turning into gases it's not
a good thing how long will that take
before that starts happening that will
start happening fairly quickly when you
equalize after you breathe out all that
air you can counteract it by having
squeezed suits like Scouten suits with
mechanical counter pressure that squeeze
it and hold it in like a blood pressure
cuff kind of pressure Oh kind of thing
so you could do that that's um promising
no no you know there's there's ways you
can you can live through it but it is
we've had this happen to people in
vacuum chambers accidents like
industrial vacuum chambers and one test
chamber and NASA once had an accident
and we've momentarily subjected people
too close to space vacuum but very
quickly got him back to pressure and
they were okay mmm
so all the bubbles just kind of like
yeah
now what is the timeline in terms of
like does SpaceX have a multiple stage
timeline like a timeline for
incorporating the dragon crew and then a
timeline for the star hopper and then a
timeline for additional projects in the
future like as is he thinking along
these lines of like a like charted out
progress oh yeah yeah he's in fact he
measures pretty much every major
decision by whether or not it brings the
day when we have a self-sustainable
colony on Mars sooner or later
that's the prism by which he makes every
like every single decision he makes
through that prism Jesus yeah so he's
got an idea and he'll keep pushing and
you know he gives us aggressive
timelines that we have to work to and we
work really hard to try to try to meet
him it's hard when you're doing stuff
that this does this complicate it to
predict exactly how long it's going to
take so you know we end up off and
falling a little bit behind but we do
our best that's the case though with
everything that's that crazy right yeah
I mean no I mean especially Elon he's
never right in his predictions all wacky
inventions they're always a little off
you know but we think but but he's so
driven you know and he's such a smart
guy and and he's he's the most he's
really the most driven person I think
I've ever met
I'll give you a story that kind of
Illustrated once when I first got hired
by SpaceX we did a interview with 60
minutes and they interviewed at Elon and
myself and Scott Pelley was the any
anchor he'd talked to us and he said to
me why did you leave NASA and come work
for SpaceX he had like the best gig in a
world you know going up on rockets and
stuff why would you do that and I said
well if you can go back in time and you
were a young engineer and you had the
opportunity to like get in on the ground
floor and work with Howard Hughes when
he was like doing all the crazy stuff he
was doing and in his day wouldn't you
want to be a part of that Scott Pelley
looked at me like with a deer in the
headlights so cuz I don't think he know
what I was talking about but I was like
that's it but then I realized this as I
say that like oh my god I just made a
terrible strategic error I compared my
boss to Howard Hughes and you know
things didn't end up that well for
Howard you know he went crazy right and
went kind of crazy became washed his
hands too much and germaphobe he was
peeing in jars and like his fingernails
grew out like hmm yeah and I was like
god no I really kind of stepped in it
right you don't say that about the boss
right so it took a while I was like
months later we were driving in a rental
car just the two of us in Florida we
were had a meeting at NASA and we were
driving back to the airport he got on
his airplane to come back to LA
and I'm driving the car he's sitting in
the passenger seat and I said hey boss
remember that time we're on TV and I
compared you that Howard Hughes you know
I just want you to know I was comparing
you to the young dashing starlet dating
Howard Hughes not the old decrepit
peeing in jars fingernail it's all about
the timeline yeah and and all I got back
was silence I'm really scared right and
I'm sitting there like waiting for him
to say something and he'll and we'll do
this and I he did this on your show
right he kind of like if you if he posed
to him a serious question he'll consider
it and he'll kind of go into this I
almost like a trance he'll stare off
into space and you can see the wheels
turning he's like focusing all of his
intellect which is considerable and
there's one question and that's what was
happening so I waited and then he turned
back to me he said you know Garrett I
don't think it's an apt comparison I
said okay good good why I'm curious why
do you think that and he said well none
at Howard none of Howard's designs as
brilliant as they were ended up really
changing the way we live our lives so we
don't send like he made the dispersed
goose which is an incredible airplane
was all wood you know trying to solve
the problem during the war of rationing
he said we don't send our our Goods
across the oceans and giant wooden
airplanes we don't do that the h1 racer
was a beautiful airplane but it was a
one-off and never really led to a large
designs that changed the way people
lived their lives so that was his
objection was not that like I was
comparing him to some creep but that he
wants it's really important to him to
have the legacy of drastically impacting
the way all of us live our lives the
kind of the way Steve Jobs did or others
that really move the ball downfield for
Humanity that's what's driving he's such
an unusual human I mean there's very
very few people that you could make any
kind of rational comparison to other
than maybe Nikola Tesla
will you really stop and think what he's
done yeah and the fact that he does the
most simultaneously that he's involved
in the boring project he's involved in
Tesla and SpaceX all simultaneously and
Tesla home solar although the solar
panels and the making solar tiles for
roofs and he's doing so many different
things at the same time it it's it's
almost impossible like it I don't
understand how he does it yeah I seen
him do it and I still don't understand
it you know it's like I've kind of
burned myself out just trying to do one
of those things yeah there's all of them
and and and he does have all the
advantages of wealth which helps you
know so like he'll have meetings with us
and he'll walk out of his last meeting
and he'll walk across the street to
Hawthorne Airport hop on his jet and
he's at Palo Alto in a couple hours and
he could be first thing in the morning
at Tesla right he's got a staff to help
some and you know he's got those
advantages but he he that isn't in any
way described what do you or that
doesn't explain why he's able to do what
he does I don't know how he does it to
be honest oh well he's the next stage of
humanity yeah if people are evolving
he's he's like looking at us from the
next spot he's like hey guys I've got
some ideas yeah he's just an idea
Factory and and he his uh what's really
remarkable to me is is is the breadth of
his knowledge
I mean I've met a lot of super super
smart people but they're usually super
super smart on one thing and he's able
to have conversations with our top
engineers about the software and you
know the most arcane aspects of that and
then he'll turn to our manufacturing
engineers and and have discussions about
some really esoteric welding process for
some crazy alloy and and he'll just go
back and forth and his ability to do
that across all the different
technologies that go into rockets and
cars and everything else he does that's
what really impresses me well also the
lack of burnout because he's been doing
it at this incredible rate sixteen hours
a day for how long is whole life I think
that's nuts I know and he's still hungry
for it and he
still taking on these new projects and
new ideas and yeah you know at that pace
seven seven years was a bad as like as
much as I could take like do something
else I just don't I you know I mean I'm
very happy exists you know yeah but it's
very confusing to me I just feel so
stupid when I'm around him the
conversations I've had with him like
goddamn I'm dumb yeah do what you got to
do with what you got I would go that far
so his uh his ultimate goal is to create
some sort of a colony on Mars but he
believes that this technology will
continue to expand to the point where we
will be leaving our solar system we will
be making human trips into other solar
systems into actual deep space yeah I
mean certainly hopefully that's you know
at some point if we're going to survive
you take the really long view you know
the solar system is not gonna last
forever right it's gonna last plenty
long and if my kids are listening at
home
don't worry freaking out right now no we
got plenty of time couple billion years
kids relax it's not in our lifetime
they're so funny but uh but eventually
we're gonna have to find a new home if
we're gonna last forever
mmm and we all hope that we last forever
as a species right so at least most of
us do so eventually we got to get there
but we got plenty of time in a short
term the important thing is at least
getting out so not in just one place in
the solar system because this you know
something bad could happen to this
planet sure we've got no backup right
and particularly if there's a natural
situation supervolcano super vodka
steroid extract more you know we're
doing a pretty good job of trash in this
place all on her own
yeah yeah we don't really need an
asteroid to hit us we're kind of going
down the road of making this place an
uninhabitable well what we need is
someone like Elon who concentrates on
the solutions I mean he's obviously got
a full plate yet many full plates but
someone like him to concentrate on
solutions to some of
environmental problems that we've
created for ourselves here well that's
really that's that was the thought
behind Tesla I mean so so Tesla's kind
of like plan a he saved this planet and
SpaceX was kind of Plan B if you look at
it that way it's just so weird to have a
guy like that amongst us you know
especially have him as your boss have
you talked to him at all about
simulation theory we never thing is what
every time I talk to him we focused on
and this is what he does you know he
focuses on the thing that we are working
on mm-hmm so he just that's one of the
ways he does his time management that's
one of the ways he's able to do all
these things it's like he doesn't sit
around and and and and and BS with you
about like what's going on with was a
neuro-link the company was making the
chips at going oh that's right I forgot
about that that's the other thing he
does that one he doesn't in the way
humans interface with data he never said
to me like Garret what do you think
about having a chip in your head that
like never he doesn't do that he talks
to the people who really know about
chips and people and putting chips in
people's head he talks to them about it
so you're gonna sign up for that no face
expression you made like no my website
got hacked and it freaked me out of how
well they're gonna put wires in your
head yeah right that's the idea behind
it idea Christ he's probably gonna be
inevitable it once it happens I mean I
don't want to be an early adopter but
once it does happen and it really does
remarkably increase your your ability to
interface with data is that's the idea
right it said it ramps up the bandwidth
in which people can access ideas and
information it's gonna change the way we
interface yeah I mean I could see it
being kind of an extreme haves and
have-nots situation like you think wow
how far behind you are today how left
behind you are if you have no internet
access right and this will be kind of
this could be like another level of that
yeah I'm worried I'm worried about that
yeah I got other things that keep me up
at night I got yeah I mean what is it
going crazy nine-year old and it
real real-world problems yeah it's just
to me it seems like if you pay attention
to the track if you track technology
look where it's going things constantly
improve they constantly we demand
constant innovation and we're already
wearing these things on our body and
watches now a lot of people were in the
Apple watches and the Samsung and all
the Google watches and it just seems
inevitable that it somehow or another
advances to a point where there's a chip
or something you wear or some plate that
they put in the back your head and screw
in yeah but then you watch like black
mirror and it is the problem in that be
good I mean but do you have a sense of
history that you are first of all you're
amongst one of the rare human beings
that has ever been in space and then to
you're working for a company that is at
the very tip of the spear of innovation
like the you are you're at the front of
the line in terms of creating viable
methods of sending people into space and
returning them I feel extremely
fortunate you know eight to have that
experience I had at NASA and had the
visceral experience the incredible
experience of flying in space doing
spacewalks operating robot arm is
launching on rockets and all that and
then coming to SpaceX and being there at
in the relatively early days and being
there for seven years I feel like you
know I feel pretty satisfied I got to
see I got incredibly lucky to see these
things and be in the room where it
happens you know it's it's pretty
remarkable and now so now I'm a now I'm
still a consultant of SpaceX but I'm a
full-time professor at USC so now I'm
teaching and I'm also working on TV
shows so now I'm like taking that those
incredible experiences I had opened up a
lot of other doors and like I ended up
it was like for example working and
working on this TV show I find myself
like in there in the writers room with a
whole bunch of really talented creative
people where there's no way in a million
years I would
so it ever happened to me if it weren't
for these incredible experiences I was
lucky enough to have you know it's like
that gets even that gets really surreal
I could only imagine I mean I can only
imagine especially coming from your
childhood having that image on your wall
and now really being a part of this
massive change in the way human beings
are going to be able to travel in space
yeah now what is tell us about this TV
show because you were talking about it
off air before we started yeah so this
this is for all mankind it's on Apple TV
and the the way I got involved with this
thing I was a big fan of Battlestar
Galactica dead the reetou reboot was
awesome wasn't it oh it's oh so
underrated yeah when the best science
fiction shows ever yeah I mean it's like
in the early days of kind of like peak
TV I guess and it was like um it was
just so good I mean the writing was so
good and the whole concept and
everything all that all the things
they're exploring and the science
fiction is always as best when it's like
an allegory and the way they explored
things that were happening in society
like terrorism and stuff the way they
were able to depict it as in a scienter
alternate universe I thought it was
spectacular yeah it's brilliant
brilliant show so I'm watching it on the
space station which was like the best
what do you what using an iPad or
something like how do you have things
stored or is there a TV up there
there's no TV but there's we have all
these laptops so you could send up files
and you can you can give them like four
shows that you like how long does it
take for a show to download in space
well they download it for you which is
nice while you're while you're working
then when you're when you're ready to
watch you just pop up the file so is it
like a satellite connection internet
satellite it's it's kind of it's a it's
a kayuu band system that goes to
satellites that aren't part of it NASA
satellites are called tigress satellites
so the data goes up to teachers and and
down at ground stations to White Sands
and then so we're gonna ban with you
getting what's your latency I don't
remember the numbers but we weren't
getting when I was there we weren't
getting live Internet
because all that bandwidth is being used
for science to get done all the data
from the experiments in the video so you
can't tor check your Twitter you can
now you can now can now I just missed
that that's terrible
yes probably yeah traction yeah yeah
just google searching random things are
you supposed to be doing your job at
space yeah so you you get these shows
and you're watching Battlestar Galactica
yeah on your lap question bouncer
galactic Colbert Report Daily Show and
like New York Yankees game someone wow
that's one watching wow you want you not
watching Yankees games in real time no
no pretty pre-recorded Wow still though
so it's just that was the nights like
like a bit at home that you know I would
play the radio broadcasts while I was
working and just in the background and
so I feel like you're the crack of the
bat and it's kind of like you're in
space but you're still kind of connected
to home that seems like something that
would go on in a movie yeah some guy
who's working about a spaceship in the
movie is listening to a baseball game go
just yet three balls two strikes yeah
doesn't that yeah it really does seem
very like some classic George Clooney
movie about space yeah that's real yeah
how weird that feels so surreal that you
were that guy up there with a laptop
yeah I mean like bow so I'm watching
Battlestar and they're like now I'm in
the final season and they're like
finding earth I'm like it's right there
you're you're in a spaceship how many
people have watched Battlestar Galactica
while in a spaceship you might be the
only person ever
well my commander is watching it too so
there's at least two of us but but so
they ask you like are there any
celebrities you'd like to chat with
while you're up there and they will go
out and get them for you the kind of
morale boosting oh wow as I said I want
to talk to Ron Moore and David Icke oh
the creators of Battlestar mm-hmm so we
had this great Skype session wow it's so
cool and that's why before I was gonna
mention this when we were talking about
you know science fiction and science
fact and had this is crazy feedback loop
about you got to think about it first
like you'd go back and look at 2001 and
you see these guys using tablets in 1960
was in 1968 that movie came out hmm
and you know Steve Jobs saw that and
said I'm gonna make one of those all
right and so there's this crazy like in
play between fiction in fact and and I
got to talk to around more about all
this and any invited me to come on the
set for the for the final episode of
Battlestar Wow
and you're not supposed to like the
first 30 days you're back from a long
duration mission you're not supposed to
like go anywhere and I'm like look
they're only gonna shoot this once you
know it's it's two weeks from now I'm
going yeah the last time I checked this
was a free country I'm not gonna stop me
so I went and I went all way up to
Vancouver and I got to go on the set I
met all the cast I got to be a focus
puller on the camera guy I got to do
that that sticks you know oh wow I just
had a blast Nate and then they made me
an extra I was a colonial Marine in the
back of a ship that gets blown up I'm
sure that show was super complicated to
make but I would love if they brought it
back yeah I don't think people
appreciated enough because it was on Sci
Fi which is not the most popular network
and it's also a reboot of a classic show
so maybe it had like a bit of a stink to
it but that was so much better than the
first version of it it's a great [ __ ]
show it's really intense yes it's really
really well made I like everything about
it from the plot to the acting it's it's
sensational yeah this is my favorite
sci-fi show of all time for sure
yeah me too it's blasphemy for Star Trek
fans yeah but it's really good it's
[ __ ] good I mean you couldn't have it
without Star Trek you couldn't have it
without the original Battlestar
Galactica but at the end of the day it's
yeah they all kind of build on each
other and that's what and so there's Ron
went off and did Outlander after that
okay and now he came in one day he calls
me up and he says I got this new idea
can I come by we can together and maybe
I could bounce the idea off of ya and I
was like yeah so he came to SpaceX and I
gave him a tour of the place and then we
sat down at the in the cafe and he said
okay so I'm thinking about doing a show
about NASA back in like the 70s and be
kind of like a period piece would be
kind of like we'd have a cast of
characters but they're all working on
Apollo and it would be true to real life
but it would be the drama of the people
behind the scenes
sounds pretty cool because yeah I'm also
toying around with a slight twist that
where we use an alternate reality and in
this alternate reality things we start
at that point but things turn out
differently and we start talking about
like how close the Russians were to
actually beating us to the moon which
not a lot of people know about but when
I was over there in Moscow I got to see
actually there in they have a warehouse
where they still have their Lunar Lander
for example that they built they were
really working hard on it so we started
what-iffing like well what if the
Russians got there first what would what
would America done how think how would
things be different today if that
seminal moment of Neil and Buzz stepping
out on the moon
was instead of letting the owner for
cosmonaut doing it right mmm I was like
that is [ __ ] genius I mean that was
like a I thought I want to see that show
that's like a great premise and he
pitched that to Apple and they bought it
and then he called me up and said would
you want to work on the show I'm like
yeah so what is your role what do you do
there I'm a technical consultant one of
a couple we have a we have a another
group of people a couple of people that
help out too but I get involved in like
everything so I was in the writers room
where we're first coming up with basic
ideas and sketching out like multiple
seasons and character arcs and all that
kind of oh and then I got then I get all
the scripts and I read them all and I
give notes on all the scripts and then
it come to the set and I meet with the
actors the cast and I give them
suggestions about like how to look real
when they're in space and then I like
work with the VFX guys I work with the
stunt team that I get phone calls from
like the hair and makeup people like how
to what the ladies do with their hair if
they have long hair when they do a
spacewalk I'm like you're calling the
wrong guy I can ask a friend right so so
so all this was so much fun for me it's
like you know you know how like you can
pay a whole lot of money and go to
fantasy baseball camp
yeah and like you get to like have
batting practice with the Dodgers or
something and they humor you because you
paid a lot of money well it's kind of
like that I keep waiting for them to say
like okay
the fun is over get out of here go back
to your day job you know but I'm like
I'm just loving it
that's wild so how much correcting do
you have to do how much do you get the
script and go eh that doesn't happen
that you can't do that that's not it
depends and every production is
different the nice thing about for all
mankind is they really really want to
get it right I've worked on other
projects where they say they want to get
it right but then they like completely
Bluff the laws of physics and and you
know I'm okay with that
the Martian with the hand cutting thing
yeah because at the end of the day like
I said this is so my student it's like
nobody goes to see a movie for the
orbital mechanics you go for the story
the characters that sure yeah but it's
hard if you're an expert in something to
watch a movie with a fudge stuff and it
doesn't make sense yeah like for me
martial arts movies martial arts movies
do dumb [ __ ] I mean come on man you know
or if I watch a movie about a pool
player and I can tell the guy can't
really play pool I get upset so for you
when you're watching something like
gravity yeah right that was a big one a
lot of people got really like Neil
deGrasse Tyson I know I hate it he hated
it hated it I liked it and the problem
is now that I have this job now I'm
getting more persnickety about it you
know I'm sure now I'm watching I'm like
that's not right well yeah everything
the gravity the hair the did not care
though like I when I first saw gravity I
loved it because it was a good story it
was it gripped me and but you knew that
those space stations were not close to
each other
oh yeah the inclinations were the orbits
are totally different there's no you're
gonna go from one to the other with a
fire extinguisher
I knew that was complete [ __ ] don't
get me wrong but that bleep were they
treating you like you're a [ __ ] they're
treating you like there's no way you're
gonna be able to research this but
something like you someone like you
rather that's your life so you know
that's nonsense so you're sitting there
watching some hokey solution
yeah for something that would never work
yeah so if it gets to the point where
like but that's a beautiful thing about
like doing this with televisions you
don't have to actually be right just
have to be believable which is the bar
is like when I'm teaching my class at
USC I gotta be right but when I'm like
yeah well maybe this could happen
you know with the TV show it's easier
but this TV show you're just saying they
really want to try to really do because
it's it's really important to them and
so yeah I've ended up making like
wholesale changes to episodes become
like the original idea I try very very
hard not to interfere with their
creative process because they're it's
really really good at that and um you
know I'm not worthy but I'm like yeah
okay I see what you're trying to do you
might this gotta be the hero you want
this person to feel remorse you want
this and and and over the course of time
this person has a change of heart I get
the story but what if instead of doing
it this way what if the events occur
like this because this could actually
happen right and somebody tried to
change it and there's one like like
episode 9 and a little bit of episode 10
of season 1 we ended up sitting I ended
up sitting and working very closely with
the writers and changing all the
technical content to fit to make the
story work in a believable way and that
when we do that and then you see it on
the screen it's like so incredibly
rewarding it's really fun that must be
especially as someone who's a sci-fi fan
like you've you've had to dream lives
here like I know you're four really
incredible that you've gone from that
from NASA to SpaceX and now to be able
to create television shows that you can
actually enjoy yeah Wow
um one things I wanted to ask you about
space is we always hear stuff about
space junk about satellites and just
junk that's floating around the
atmosphere how much of a concern is that
and what could be done about that stuff
it's a huge concern it's a very very big
problem in in in certain orbits around
the earth low Earth orbit and also at
the geostationary orbits that are very
that's where you could put like
communications satellites and they stay
over one spot of the earth those are
very polluted you know there's a lot of
junk and it is very dangerous and it's
it's a real problem is hard to clean up
over time eventually even even at higher
altitudes there's still a little bit of
atmosphere like individual atoms
eventually that slows you down those
collisions eventually slow you down so
eventually it comes back but it could
take a long long time come back to earth
you mean yeah
they'll come back and he'll burn up so
the most important thing is don't make
any more junk that's like the best thing
we can do and we're getting much smarter
they get SpaceX we take our second
stages and all of our NASA missions and
after after we it's accomplished its
mission we keep enough gas in the tank
to burn the engine one more time and
bring it back in one piece so it doesn't
blow up into smithereens and cause more
junk whenever we do anti-satellite test
though China did one relatively recently
and we've done them in the past those
are like the worst because they create
giant clouds of junk and and we have to
still we still have to live with that is
there any concepts on the table for how
to do that stuff out there's some ideas
of you know using lasers that lays the
things and and and and and make subtle
changes to their trajectories and orbits
but it's all that all the technical
solutions are challenging and expensive
so I don't know of any one idea that's
gonna like just solve this problem
easily because we've seen the map of the
earth and all the different satellites
that orbit it now and all the different
jump pieces of junk that have been
identified it's crazy yeah the amount of
stuff and it seems like nobody kind of
thought it through they just sort of did
it and left the junk up there and that's
what humans do man I mean like we've
been dumping stuff in the oceans forever
yeah and not really giving much thought
to it and now we're funny giant gyros of
plastic or them you know yeah so yeah we
tend to not really react until it's a
really big problem but it's a big
problem and and when I did my first
spacewalk one of the things we had to do
was we had to bring in his handle they
were going to use on a subsequent
spacewalk it was like it was we call it
D handle it's just basically a half-inch
piece of aluminum around like like this
that you can attach to something then
carry things so we had this big chunk of
aluminum and we brought it inside in my
spacewalk partner Rick looked at the
thing when we came inside to saw a hole
shot straight through it
it's like about a millimeter in diameter
it's really small but it went right
through this half-inch thick solid
aluminum and he looked at that and he
said man if that hit one of us
and he didn't have to finish that
statement because if this stuff is
moving generally speaking about 10
kilometers per second so that's like
roughly 10 times as fast as a rifle
bullet so something like that hits you
it could be a Fleck of paint hitting you
at that velocity in the hitch in the
suit you're in a hundred percent oxygen
environment and you're just gonna flame
up I mean you're gonna instantly combust
it's gonna be a really a bad day so he
didn't have to like you said you know
when he said that he didn't have to
finish it and we both looked at it and
then I looked at him and said yeah but
you're six foot four so statistically
it's gonna hit you more object and
beside that was kind of behind you most
of the way out there but I probably go
right through him and right through you
to hit probably him like that's what's
so crazy about is there's so much of
that stuff up there I'm always wondering
like why doesn't it hit the space
station what it does does a couple of
times I was inside the space station I
heard us take a hit whoa but just but so
I heard the ping but fortune I didn't
hear the ping fall but a change yeah so
that ping is probably something bouncing
off something or going through something
so the station has shielding it's called
whipple shielding and it's basically a
piece of a wall a thin piece of metal
that stands off from the hull so the
thin piece of metal is never going to
stop this thing but it when it hits at
that hyper velocity it breaks up into
lots of little tiny pieces and it's
almost like a fluid at that point it's
like these like it's like it like almost
a cloud of dust and then when it hits
the hull those individual pieces don't
penetrate hmm so it just it just
shatters it and that what that works
what if it hits that window it has hit
the shuttle window you know we've it has
multiple panes and it's really really
strong but we came home with big it
looks like like when a rockets kicked up
and it takes really yeah we've we've
seen that yeah wow that's a little scary
Jesus Christ a little chest
what about micro meteors and things
along those lines well depending on
where you are so in in Earth orbit
there's much more of manmade junk than
there
micrometeorites but there are those too
when you get out away from Earth orbit
like if we're gonna go back to the moon
then there's no more human-made junk but
there is those micro meteorites are
still out there and they can do the same
kind of damage but there's a lot fewer
of them the density of those things is a
lot less than what you experience so
it's if you go to Mars I'd worry about
the radiation first and then the micro
meteoroids I like down the list it just
seems to so many things to think about
yeah and is this all factored into your
television show uh well a lot of these
things are I can't can't say I can't
give any spoilers but Susan one is
available right now it is all we can
talk about that but season two I am NOT
allowed to give any spoilers or anything
but I can tell you this like yeah
there's some of these concepts end up in
there yeah well listen it's been a real
pleasure having you in here man I really
appreciate you coming here and talking
about the stuff and you've lived three
amazing lives a third one right now and
it's you've had a pretty cool one too
man so now this has been a real honor
and a real pleasure the honors mine man
thank you very much so one more time for
people it's available right now on Apple
TV for all mankind for all mankind and
if people want to find you on social
media do you have yes you can go to my
website Garrett Riesman calm thank you
and then on Twitter and Instagram I'm
Astro G dog with - gee thanks brother
appreciate you being here man my
pleasure thank you bye everybody
[Music]